and then saturday night i see ken jong
at the laugh factory we
did a show together and um
he's a friend i like him a lot he's
talented guy
but he's just like um oh aquafina really
likes you
like out of nowhere yeah and i want to
say hey cha-cha
hey chicha i knew aquafina way before
you bro
yeah yeah i mean my foot my foot and my
feet
and my fingers on the pulse america i
was friends with her first she was he
was she was friends with her first
wait how did you et cetera et cetera
youtube bro
social media brother years ago through
social media
she just randomly started following me i
think through asa or dvda essay or
something like that
yeah and then we just became you know
pen pals
i went to david cho's house you hear
about that no what happened
so david chill goes um if you guys don't
know who david cho is then go [ __ ]
yourself because he's american
sweetheart
american that's what i'm just calling
him he's america's sweetheart it's like
betty white yeah yeah and he
uh he's apple pie and um machetes
yep yeah if you take apple pie machetes
and um some sort of dumpling
yeah that's david chow and cho was like
hey man uh let me do a portrait of you
at my house
yeah oh right i saw a picture of that so
dude dog i was just like
dude he's like a talented artist right
yeah so i go i'm gonna zip on over to
koreatown
and go to his house i go in his house
and he paints the first painting he does
is a painting of a banana if this is a
banana with slitty eyes
you're sitting there yeah and i'm
watching him doing i go damn me bro
all right american pie so then
he goes this is not working i go sure
ain't
and he takes paint and he puts it all
over my face
into my ears you saw the photo it's on
my instagram and he's doing this while
you're just sitting there sitting there
he's interviewing me for his own thing
there's paint on my arms my head in my
pits yeah in my belly button everywhere
right and then he goes that's the piece
like what dude i want a painting so i
can hang in my house
it'd be cool to say that's a david cho
that he painted of me but i'm never
going to get that from him
unless you want a banana with slime
today yeah which is still a david show
piece
still david i guess equally as special
equally special and then i did that and
then um
and then we we renamed our dog we talked
about already
well we have to let everyone know that
this was another foster fail but it
wasn't my idea
it's 100 your idea
and your fault friend okay because as
soon as you said
you were gonna i swear to god he called
it yeah he did i swear to god we're
gonna get rid of this one
yeah right and i'm like we'll see he's
such a gaslighter
who me yeah you alter like you alter
reality and perception so much so and
you believe it
so deeply strange
if you're that's what i am i'm a
gaslighting doctor strange yeah because
i don't know how you're flipping this
story because i was right about to hand
them
in fact the last time that i i i um took
um fritter who is now julio which was
iggy at one point
yeah it went from fritter to iggy's
julio i took him to
his last try